hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et tu table le styliste dû
cliquer sur démarrer pour que notre
aventure commence je t'attends rejoint
vite sur messenger ya eu un truc énorme
y avait un truc énorme qui regarde
chaque fois que ces bonnes âmes a
dévoilé via notre coiffeur s'est passé
il ya jet le contenu ils étaient tous
contents d'avoir coiffé nadège d'aia
joie postulat recoiffer jeff et il est
tout content et regarder ce qui se passe
à l'antenne c'est que le gars eux mais
d'ici au jour tranquille
halak a cédé à la caméra la plus
importante issue
ouais
jeff guess qu'est le coiffeur qu'est le
coiffeur de l'édition nadège que tu fous
là bas ta place
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui voilà pourquoi vous êtes
mais tous comme ça lorsque nathan et on
attend julien lepers
ah mais oui